some cold snooze Reggie Wayne it's gonna
be inducted into the Colts Ring of Honor
this season that's one step closer to
Reggie possibly being in the Hall of
Fame some day so now since this whole
thing went down
Reggie Wayne deserves it congratulations
to him Reggie's the best that we love
Reggie Wayne at the NFL Network and I've
gotten to know him I'm just wondering if
he's the Paul Pierce who could be the
who could be the Isiah Thomas Oh to get
the attribute video on the big night and
see well Reggie likes it Jim thorgy I
got it McAfee is Pat McAfee on the phone
line he's other photos he's one of the
old-time greatest Pat McAfee bar stools
Pat McAfee how are you PAC be there rich
how's it going good how are you better
for chatting with you
Pat so what do you think can we get you
a tribute video and Reggie Wayans night
what do you think no way bad idea rich
now listen Reggie and I was teammates
just seven years ma never had a real
conversation with them not one I mean
there's been a couple like hi how's it
going not really even that really
there's just a couple one words here or
there I'm not for everybody rich and I
think Reggie was the one that made me
realize that but we're talking about one
of the hardest workers I've ever seen in
my entire life never took a day off
always did extra works on jugs machine
wait but it's just an incredible work
ethic but he and I were not like good
friends I don't think this is the right
moment for this I think all right so
then let's let's figure out when the
right time would be and and the first
things first is what I think we need to
we need to figure out what is on the
tribute video what is on the Pat McAfee
tribute video that should be inflated
Lucas Oil what do you got for me Pat
lead off with that mug shot
embarrassment to my family and to Bill
Polian okay that's one how about blowing
up trending holiday what about him I
think we should put that
there for sure I mean I was sore for a
week after that it was a blind squirrel
finding it's not but I definitely think
we should put that on there was a big
moment did you get drug tested after
that did they test you that's not random
right rich we all know it because I
would I would have a big band and I'd be
like yup no I'm gonna get something
tomorrow
limitary would have a big deal you're
getting tested tomorrow Hasselbeck -
right Hasselbeck out that treatment -
right Hasselbeck also almost died one
game when he Eddie he had what it wasn't
chlamydia it was a coli salmonella by
the way who who by the way cheated off
me in high school guy named salmonella
no I'm just kidding so okay so that the
trending holiday hit the mug shot come
on there had to be a big a big coffin
corner moment for you
Pat right yeah I'm in against the
Tennessee Titans I need a coffin corner
we had a pick six the next play I mean
it was getting morning touchdown that
goes on there you have to do the fake
against the Pittsburgh Steelers on
Thanksgiving I have a perfect passer
rating then there was the fake against
the site and there's a couple onside
kicks for sure but really what I want to
be remembered most for yes it's just my
absolute great time that I would have
during games on the sidelines and I
think if you could get captured videos
of me celebrating with Robert Mathis and
Dwight Freeney in a way that I was not
supposed to be where I was it was not
very much loved but everybody's
celebrating some giving high-fives
everybody and I'm just sneaking in
celebrations I think that was truly my
legendary moment so whose night do we
barge in on Peyton's who else what else
we can what do you think hey Peyton had
the night every night though he was a
saint ona 500 the other day just hitting
on her down there because he's got a
jingle Damon's got every night I don't
think you want to interrupt her pain
tonight
I think if Bennett Perry has a nice okay
yes I think yes I think we slide me in
there mostly because you know he's used
to dealing with me Reggie those guys
didn't have to deal with me on a regular
basis Benny did he would get the joke
he'd understand Adams coming back again
I who knows when the night's gonna be
true it's - well by the way
Shepler reported that per source he
heard Benny
that finitary on my show has said like
15 times that he's got probably two
years left he's got a record he's got to
go get and he's still kicking at an
elite level so that is a guarantee for
sure
will he be with the coats or not that's
a big decision who knows and beloved
around here by the way before I let you
go Pat McAfee speaking of your media
career you asked the question of Frank
Reich that got the soundbite of the day
when he was uh when he was at his press
conference Pat you got the soundbite of
the day thanks to your question I
preached it I can't believe they let me
in there now where you you were there
you were there in your full uniform now
I'm not talking football uniform right
Pat yeah I had a I didn't see my thought
I've never been a part of the press
conference rich okay you guys didn't
talk to me much whenever I was funnier
yes cuz really there's not much to say I
mean how did you punch so good bad it
really won us the game is never a
question that is asked well I'm not one
to know what press conferences are not I
just thought it was a casual situation
go in there some shorts cutoff what do
you hat and I didn't realize it was also
a celebration for Frank the new head
coach yeah I was definitely underdressed
they didn't give me the microphone for a
while was like trying to get the
bartender's attention they're trying to
get the mic and then I finally got it
and Frank Reich and I go way back
he was my quarterback coach back
whenever I was a rookie cuz I was third
string emergency and he and I are good
friends and I asked him a question that
everybody was thinking I can't believe
nobody else asked and he hit a homerun
that's all I think Frank's gonna be a
great coach too because the guys late on
it so he's funny relatable and
incredibly smart the question was do you
hate or love josh mcdaniels right that
was your question of them yep and yeah I
mean I well first thing was like how do
you make Andrew Luck magical because
what happened with Posen whence I
thought that was beautiful right and
then I follow up to that question which
is a standard big J journalist follow-up
to that question is do you hate or love
Josh McDaniels for what happened I'll
hang up and listen to your answer I
honestly like the Indianapolis Colts
fans they looked at that Josh McDaniels
situation as another reason to hate the
Patriots right like that's another
reason to hate the Patriots
it wasn't like that big of like an
embarrassing situation for Coach fans as
it was well there's another reason to
hate the Patriots but Frank right these
sounds got to be like you know what I
like this guy like what he did and pray
delivered a gem with that backup role
has suited me well in my career and and
and that's a mic drop at McAfee
alright so we've got the tribute video
we're gonna will help put it together
and then inventory when he when he has
his night we're gonna have that sort of
you'll be the Isiah Thomas to his Paul
Pierce that night pack cool like that I
really appreciate that I mean it doesn't
put me in a terrible for the brand Pat
anything for the brand's you know for
the brand take care bud
I think thanks for Cole you got that's
Pat McAfee the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience